[Music]
[Applause]
we talked to Getty Lee yesterday so uh
we'll get to that in a moment Christies
and Hunt auctions proudly present
selections from Getty Lee the important
baseball memorabilia it's his collection
historic offering that you have uh going
back for many many Century or decades
here live auction will take place
December 6 the pieces are available to
look at December 1st through December
5th for more information visit
christies.com here is how I started my
interview with the lead singer of the
band Rush Getty Lee we were trying to
play guest Getty Lee's favorite baseball
player growing up now you save your
answer let's go around the room Getty
Lee's favorite baseball player growing
up
Todd Greg luzinski Greg luzinski sat no
Conor Sandy kofax
Marvin Mickey Manel T Paulie Harmon kerw
I'm going Al
Kaline oh God you guys are torturing me
uh yeah Al Kaline oh nicely thank you
thank you thank you um what was the did
you meet Al no never met him uh but you
know we were in a a Zone where we got
the American League games on the
weekends and so the the Tigers Yankees
rivalry was the thing when I was growing
up and we saw a lot of Tigers games and
and uh I believe uh the Toronto Maple
Leaf ball team that was uh located in
Toronto with the international league
team I think they were the farm club of
the Tigers for a while and and the one
or two games I managed to sneak downtown
and watch when I was really young I
think even Sparky Anderson was on that
club so I had a familiarity with guys
like alcaline Norm cash uh you know that
was a great era and of course Mickey
Manel and Roger Maris were the thing
when I was a kid too so I was fans of
them as well first piece of memorabilia
you remember buying was
what um it was
a um it was a photograph of Satchel Page
that was signed by him and I bought that
at the same time as a photo photograph
of uh the the shot uh signed by uh Bobby
Thompson those two pieces I was walking
through a memorabilia store and I I
didn't collect that stuff yet and so I
saw these two pieces I thought wow
though they would look really cool
hanging in my office so uh but then it
becomes an
addiction yes right when did you realize
that it was out of
hand
um last
year
okay um it's been out of hand for quite
a while it's my nature uh you know the
problem I have is not that I'm a
borderline hoarder or that uh I'm a
passionate collector is that I have this
kind of completest attitude to
collecting so for example when I started
collecting no hitter balls well I I had
to have every no hitter ball that I
could possibly find and so um it's that
part of the ill
that has caused me to have so much stuff
that I couldn't even display it all so
you know we used to be a collector was
pretty good and then they started
labeling us hoarders and yes and then it
became a negative so I have a man cave
full of stuff and just stuff that I've
collected when I was at ESPN and you
know probably 40 years worth but I have
this huge building that I can put it in
I do you have a big building that you
have all of this stuff in or did know
did you run out of space well I ran out
of space I you know I have incredible
office at home where I displayed all my
favorite pieces and I couldn't really
display them all I had boxes and boxes
of wonderful pieces that I'd completely
forgotten about and uh and then when I
started collecting Bas vintage based
guitars I had a real problem I had a
critical mass issue at my
home so how many how many guitars did
you have about 350 oh my God yeah yeah
you collected from bands like other
artists uh not so much I was just
interested in in vintage pieces rare
pieces a lot of a lot from what I call
the Golden Age of guitar making which
was the late 50s early
60s uh and you know again being a
completist I had to have one of each
brand even obscure Italian brands that
that were made and not many seen on this
uh side of the world what's the most you
spend on a piece of
memorabilia uh guitar or uh baseball
baseball oh I don't know over a 100
Grand I have spent yeah but you got
uniforms you got uniforms as well bats
as
well yeah uh I really tried to focus on
single signed baseballs or game used
baseballs uh but you know uh it's all
fascinating to me that sometimes in a
bat like I have a bat that might have
been used by Joe Jackson but it's one of
his uh signature bats and how do you not
uh try to grab that if you're a
collector I have a lot of personal
memorabilia that I would never part with
uh for my collection stuff like I have
Bill Lee's uniform uh the day that he
freaked out in the Montreal expose
Clubhouse because Rodney Scott had been
traded he took off his exposeed uniform
tore it up and then head headed to the
bar across the street to have a few
pints and Jim Fanning picked up who was
the manager of the Expos at the time he
picked up the uniform and kept it all
these years and I got to know Jim
through Larry Walker who's a friend of
mine and a really nice family and they
you know allowed me to purchase it from
them for my collection but that's
something that's so special because I'm
a Canadian and because I was the Expos
were my first real passionate love I
have an autograph baseball from Joe
Carter and Mitch Williams on a World
Series Baseball they both signed that
that year that they I don't know what
it's worth but I I visited both of them
that off season after Joe hit the Home
Run and I asked Joe if he would sign it
and then Mitch signed it as well but
what struck me though Getty is I asked
Joe Carter where the Home Run ball was
and he said right there in the kitchen
so I open up a kitchen drawer and the
ball rolls out and I go that's one of
the most famous Baseballs in history he
goes yeah but I gave it to my wife it
was it wasn't in a trophy case it was in
a junk
drawer well you know that's this is you
know he played the game so to him it's
just a tool of the trade you know
sometimes that's it's like that I have
memorabilia from Rush passes and things
from important gigs and shows and you
know they're just collecting in some
drawer or something so I understand that
feeling whereas if it was from baseball
for me that would be just sacran you
know you've got to put it in a special
place you have a baseball sign by The
Beatles I do yeah and that's Beatles
yeah at Shay Stadium uh at that gig that
famous gig they did at sha stadium in
the 60s what do you think that'll go for
I have no idea but it could go very high
it could very well be one of the highest
uh uh selling items in the sale what
what are the top end items you think as
far as this auction at
Christy's well it's hard for me to guess
I'm so close to these things and I've
had so many of them for decades but the
Beatles ball for sure I think that some
of the presidential stuff especially the
John Kennedy first pitch 19 61 I mean
that's an amazing ball I was very
fortunate to acquire and in fact I was
very fortunate to acquire a few John
Kennedy signed
baseballs um in fact in 1961 he was the
he's one of the few presidents that
threw a first pitch out to both teams
that now that's a
Democrat um yeah there's some other
great things I have uh Johnny vmir final
outs from his backto back no hitters
that's pretty darn special man see that
one is wild we'll never have that again
and the fact that you got the final out
on both of those no
hitters yeah I I might had to have them
both you know uh it's the same with the
Kennedy uh
61 uh sign balls I once I I bought the
the first one that's also signed by
Lynden Johnson many many years ago and
uh I thought it was the only one and
then up Pops this other one on S for
sale and it's the other team and I
thought well this has got to be a fake
because I have the original one but it
turns out he did in fact throw two
pitches out that day we're talking to
Getty Lee uh are you still introduced as
the lead singer of
Rush that's what I'm kind of known for
so yeah that's fine lead singer basis of
Rush yeah but last time I talked to you
that was a couple years ago you said you
were done this probably six years ago
but uh so are you done
well uh Rush uh you know Neil Pier our
drummer retired in 2015 and sadly he uh
suffered from glol blastoma for a few
years and he passed away in 2020 so Rush
as a unit of Neil Alex and myself of
course was over in
2015 uh whether I will play again in
some form that's very possible uh I
Leave Myself quite open to that I just
finished u a 2-year epic writing my
Memoir and which is coming out today as
a matter of fact and um that was a a
great distraction and a real cathartic
process for me but uh now that that's
done I'm kind of anxious to get back to
my day job and see if I can write some
music that people still care about my
effing life that is uh the engrossing
tale of a classic underachiever who
became a Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
vocalist basis and keyboard player it's
like somebody wrote that for me
Getty but you guys aren't known for
being like the stones in the south of
France when they were doing Exile on
Main Street like you weren't going crazy
as a party ban were
you um well no we we flew under the
radar you see because we didn't have any
mainstream media attention you know we
were kind of a cult band like the
world's most popular cult band and so
whatever transgressions we happen to get
inv D and you know remained quiet so I
found it in my heart to share some of
those crazy moments my book that some
people I think might be a little
surprised to read did you give me the
band you partied with one time and lived
at tan
it oh I remember a fantastic uh number
of nights with uh the band UFO when they
were touring with us and uh we had I
remember uh some of the guys in Thin
Lizzy chall chenging us to a scotch
drinking contest and be very careful
when you challenge a Canadian to a
drinking contest we're a Hardy breed up
North so yeah and there's a time that we
had a party at the end of a Kiss tour
where uh the drummer of Kiss ended up
throwing a giant potted Palm over a
balcony out God thankfully no one was
hit so there are a few stories and then
there are some self-contained stories
about time in Manchester England when
Alex had challenged our 6
foot1 um stage manager to a cognac
drinking contest now that is not
advisable because conac is a sipping
Brew right you don't do shots of that
that is a very funny tale I have to say
bit too long and uh you know censored to
share here uh I love you man with Paul
Rudd and Jason seagull when you first
heard about what they were were doing
what was your reaction and what your
role would be in
that well we were coming out of a time
uh you have to remember we had just sort
of survived a five-year Hiatus where
Neil had had some terrible tragedies in
his life and we were not sure that he
would come back to the band but he did
thankfully for for the world of uh Rush
fans and for me personally um and so
when we embarked on that tour we were of
a completely different mindset things
that we would normally say no to out of
hand we now decided you know like that
famous Seinfeld episode if you know
every Instinct you have is wrong then
the opposite must be right so we just
started saying yes to everything and
John Hamburg had gotten the script to I
love you man to us we read it and we
said this is a comedy this is good yes
we'll do it and that's how it all
started and of course when we got to the
set we had no idea how much fun we'd
have and the guys and in the movie were
so kind and so excited and it was just
one of the best memories I have and then
you were with Paul Rudd last night yes
Paul very kindly agreed to be my
surprised guest host last night at the
Beacon Theater and he was as charming
and affable as you could ever expect you
know he's just one of the nicest people
in Show Business honest to God what a
what a sincere guy well we'll come full
circle because that's who Al Kine was he
was a wonderful gentleman
and uh having met him a couple of times
I know you said that that was your idol
when you were growing up you would have
been proud to know that that was your
Idol because he was a great man well I'm
I'm really happy to know that because I
never did meet him and uh that makes me
that makes me smile thanks good luck
with the book good luck with the auction
and there's no shame in starting a new
collection there Getty nothing wrong
with nothing wrong always always
something else to collect thanks for
joining us thanks Dan great to be here
that's Getty Lee and you can see the
items that he is going to be auctioning
off at christies.com